(whistle blows)
(shouting)
- [Man] We've got a big mix
of everybody in the club.
Gay, straight, bi, whatever,
and everyone is welcomed.
The club has completely changed my life.
(piano music)
- [Woman] BMW proudly
supports the LGBTQ community.
(chattering)
(players shouting)
- [Robert] The challenges that
the people were facing in the
1990s were fairly standard.
There was an automatic
link between being gay
and being pedophile.
You certainly couldn't be macho.
When I heard about the formation
of the world's first gay rugby club,
I thought I just gotta join in
and help in whatever way I can.
(players shouting)
- [Matt] I think Kings Cross
Steelers was the first gay
and inclusive rugby club founded in 1995.
(light switch clicks)
And we currently have 250 active members.
Our club is made up of gay, bisexual,
and straight guys who are all here to play
and enjoy rugby together.
There's many guys who self
exclude themselves in sports.
Don't want to take part at school,
who then want to get back into a sport
in their adult years and need
a social group in the society.
- [Matthew] Well, I've
wanted to get into rugby
and something a lot my family have played,
but I wasn't too comfortable
joining one of the teams
back at (mumbles).
(players shouting)
I wouldn't feel as comfortable
joining a club that doesn't
label itself as inclusive
because you've got that little niggle
in the back of your head,
like will they accept me for being gay?
Will they not?
Whereas, here, they all very accepting
and I know that it won't be an issue.
I thought I would just
be here to play the sport
in an open and friendly environment.
Instead, the club has
become another family.
Being in an inclusive
environment and (mumbles)
it's just great.
(violin music)
- [Robert] From, six
people in November 1995,
and a small committee, and
not being able to form a team,
through to having Steelers
fielding up to six teams
in any given time.
(players chattering)
It's a wonderful pleasure.
I want, and everybody in the club
wants, people to enjoy playing
rugby at whatever level,
but at the same time, being able to say,
"I'm gay," and it doesn't matter.
Society has changed so much
over the last 20 years,
and I just like to think
that we as a rugby club
have contributed in
some small way to them.
(music fades out)